I did think that momentarily we lost Bryce because when he slipped and fell. Although he did just kill a spider for me, a little that was in the car a little while ago. Give me the mic, give me the mic. Get some Haskell folks on, get some closure folks on. We, the only place that we know for certain that we want to go on this trip is Nigeria, but we're very open to going to other. We encountered many naked people. I have been pretty concerned every time you have boldly dove into the water.
Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 144, recorded on June 21st, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue to record live from our Slovenia 2023 road trip from three different countries today, Slovenia, Croatia, and Italy. In today's episode, we talk about our plans for our upcoming 2024 road trip to Nigeria and potentially other African countries, as well as recap the story of how Bryce almost died. But why shorter talks? Wait, are we recording now? Yeah. Listen, folks.
Brian! We're not going to have time to do the full intro. Let's just... I want to talk about this. No. Okay, we'll talk about it. But, folks, we're on our way to Croatia. We just
left Peran. Absolutely beautiful. We'll talk about it more later, because this is just a short recording, and we are going to talk about lots of things about Peran. Like, I kind of tried to kill me. Just a little teaser. Listen, that was your detour you wanted to take. Don't at me for almost falling off a cliff
and dying, okay? That was all on you. We will give you the full story on that later. But when we were in Paran on the tip of the Istrian Peninsula, we had a pretty brilliant idea, I think. I wouldn't go as far to say that, but we were having, we were,
we'll recap the truffle dinner. I think it was supposed to be five course. It ended up being four. Yeah, whatever happened in that fifth course? I don't know. But the truffle ice cream. It was good enough that it didn't matter. Absolutely amazing. And in the midst of this dinner, after quite a few glasses of wine, before the grappa, I'm sorry for shooting it.
I'd never heard a grappa before like 24 hours ago. Even I knew what grappa was and I had never drank alcohol. Listen, I am not a big hard alcohol person. I don't like shots. I don't like hard alcohol. I don't know the difference between whiskey and scotch. I apologize to all the fine Italian people. Anyways, we'll talk about that more later. Right now, we're chatting about our quote-unquote brilliant idea, as Bryce called it, which is our 2024 road trip. That's road trip in quotes because that's just the term we're going to use now for our international tours. But there will not be a road trip component of this trip for reasons that will become evident.
Yeah, so we're probably not going to do this annually. But until, you know, while we both don't have children and, you know, dependents and whatnot, we might as well take advantage of it. So, for the time being, annual road trip 2024 taking place in the continent of Africa. Woo! Yeah. We're going to go to Nigeria. We're going to go to Kenya. What are the other countries that we're going to go to?
I think our itinerary is going to be we're going to fly into Morocco, maybe spend a day there. And then we're going to go to Nigeria, probably go to a few different cities in Nigeria. And then we're going to go to Kenya. And then I think we're going to go home. Yeah, not finalize the plans. We still got to do some research. The goal here is we want to go to all of the nascent growing
tech hubs in Nigeria because this trip this was mostly just for the two of us for fun, but a couple times during the trip we've said to ourselves, you know, it would have been really cool to have had a meetup with you know, like maybe in Ljubljana, it would have
been cool to have had a meetup with some local C++ developers, talk to some people, talk to some of these fans that have made us the eighth largest tech podcast in Slovenia. We don't have fans. We have listeners. We have listeners, not fans. That's right. I have fans. Connor doesn't have fans.
I do not have fans. I don't want fans. I just want people. I don't even, if people want to listen, they can listen, you know? Yeah. But so then we were thinking, talking about where do we go next. And Connor had this great idea that, you know, we should, next time we should plan ahead. We should set up some meetups and some talks at some universities and, you know, connect with some people.
And we thought that it would be great to do it in some areas that are developing into big tech hubs, maybe areas that have been underlooked by the tech industry. And for us to go there and partner with some locals who are in tech and to put together some meetups where we give a couple talks and then maybe we get some locals to give a couple talks and meet some people. And so that's the idea. And our first, our immediate thought was, well, we should do this in Africa. The one place that I think we know for sure we want to go to is Nigeria because it is a very large country.
We actually have this podcast. How large? Because remember, folks, I don't care. I'll figure out what episode it was. But at some point, I said that I knew the five most populous countries. And I think I got the top four in the correct order. But then I couldn't get the fifth. And the fifth was Nigeria at 200 million people, which is like right behind the United States.
It's like, what is the U.S.? It's 130 million or 330 million last time I checked. And yeah, Nigeria. I wouldn't even – is it correct to even call it nascent at this point? I feel like Nigeria might be one of the biggest like tech capitals. There's the U.S. and then what after? China? I definitely think it is.
But I think that it is a new enough phenomenon and tech in Africa in general is a new enough phenomenon that it's not traditionally a place that you think of as being a big tech hub. We are driving and there's a tractor on the side of the road that is blocking traffic that seems
to be having some problems. But yeah, I mean, it's a big country. We, both Connor and I personally know a number of younger, absolutely brilliant programmers from Nigeria, some who are in Nigeria, some who were born and raised in Nigeria and now are in other places. And we think it'd be a great location.
So I think our goal is we're going to try to connect with universities and maybe companies in particular to try to plan and organize some of these meetups and events. I mean, I think it's better to try and partner with a local tech company because as cool as it would be to go to a university, that's less exciting for, I think, both students slash tech professionals. When I'm in Silicon Valley, it's way
cooler to go do the LinkedIn HQ in Sunnyvale, which has a really cool meet-up presentation spot, and they always got good food. Versus uh versus like it's cool to go to stanford and palo alto but uh not as cool as going to linkedin hq we are we are about 20 meters from the uh slovenian croatian border so in just a moment we are going to be in croatia
assuming that there's no sort of security check here. Not sure what's going on. I think we're good. Everybody else seems to be driving through. And I don't believe we need that little sticker thing. Four, three, two, one. Bye, Slovenia. We'll be back in a couple hours. Actually, according to the Google Maps, I'm pretty sure that this is the checkpoint that's
before the border. I'm pretty sure the border is. Right, folks. That was nuts. Yeah, we are still in... Alright, we'll do that again. Five, four,
three, two, one. Happy Croatia! I do believe we are now in Croatia It feels good Let's get some of that Croatia air Woohoo Yeah
That's pretty nice Croatia The soccer team that never dies Because they always make it To the semifinals of the World Cup Even though their team Is of questionable talent compared to some of the other teams. Wow. Wow.
I mean, that's just a fact. That's just a fact. We're not going to turn this into a football episode. I mentioned the word soccer while I was at dinner a couple nights ago, and they were like, ah, we know where you're from now. You're not from here because it is football, not soccer. All right. Well, fortunately, this episode won't're from now. You're not from here because it is football, not soccer. All right. Well, fortunately, this episode won't air until after we're out of Croatia,
so we don't have to worry about getting, you know, murdered by some excited Croatian soccer fans. Well, what are you saying about the people of Croatia that they're going to come and... I'm saying that the people... What I am saying is that the people of Croatia, I'm certain, would defend the honor of their soccer team. And I feel good about that statement. That's true.
That's true. But anyways, so yes, we were talking about what sort of talks should we give on this 2024 Africa trip. And what did you suggest? Bryce doing a terrible job with the mic. Just disappointed me the whole time while he's talking. But I'll repeat what he said in case it was not audible. We were chatting about what would be a good topic. So I think the format is going to be shorter talks in order to leave some time for more of a Q&A, AMA.
I think students specifically, I'm not sure if the tech professionals are going to have, you know, questions and whatnot. But if my guess is that there's, what are you doing? Are you kidding me? I had my blinker on my guy. All right. Well, I tried to make a left-hand turn into a merge lane and this guy just whipped around me. First of all, it's not a left-hand turn because you weren't turning, you were merging. Merging. It's a left-hand merge because you weren't turning, you were merging. Merging,
it's a left-hand merge. Look at that, it's beautiful. That is beautiful. Yeah, that's where we just were. Oh, I meant the airport that we can see. No, I was just kidding. It is absolutely gorgeous here on the Istrian Peninsula. Anyway, so I think shorter talks, probably like 20 minutes, 30 minutes,
I think a good topic would be, you you know how to uh things you can do easy things you can do to make yourself marketable to companies whether that your plan is to stay in nigeria or if you're trying to travel abroad things like you know get up projects etc and then we also want to give the opportunity i'm not sure how we would do that uh how to choose a couple students or people to give also sort of 20, 30-minute talks. Or maybe we just do like a bunch of lightning talks. We try and highlight a bunch of stuff. That's a good idea. And also, too, I mean, we said talk to the local C++ talent.
But in another conversation, we were talking about how, I mean, we've said this across multiple episodes but we always fail to uh sort of stay true to this is that we want to make this more of a poly polyglot podcast than being just c plus plus as uh first class language and then you know uh rust as a you know you know second tier uh i think we want to try, you know, get some Haskell folks on, get some Clojure folks on, you know, even maybe talk to the Java people, you know? Talk to Java. And, yeah, that's the basic idea. Hey, I hear that Java
has Instance main now or whatever. You can write main as a function so that their hello world is nicer. Java 21, we'll link it in the show notes, folks. Making a comeback. There's a couple different videos. I think one was from Fireship on YouTube.
Another one is from also Fireship. If you're listening, which I don't think you are, you stole my YouTube channel name and my handle. You can't just go and make a code report series because now anytime someone Googles code report, that's the first thing that comes up. Back off. Back off, Fireship. I know where you live. first thing that comes up. Back off. Back off, fire ship. I know where you live. I know where you live. Connor does not know where you live.
No, no. I don't know where you live. And I assure you, even if he did, he's a gentle giant. Although he did just kill a spider for me. Oh, that was in the car a little while ago. Oh, yeah. Give me the mic. Give me the mic.
Wait. I got to make this left-hand turn. All right. We made the left-hand turn successfully. Holy smokes, folks. We've learned a lot about Bryce on this trip. I think I have been very upfront that I am a sissy about spiders. Man.
Yeah, we've learned a lot about Bryce, but holy smokes, did I see... I'm not even sure I would call you a full-grown man. Whatever you are, crumbled into a small baby. This dude was quivering, and we were like halfway up a parking exiting the parking this dude exited the vehicle and was like you got to deal with that for me man and i was like what what are we doing man we're both in our 30s this is this this is a this is a fear so so serious and and and so deep in me that i'm not even embarrassed about it that it's just like okay like i just i want the whole world to know so that I never have to be exposed to a spider.
So that everybody will understand that this is like, yes, I am a small, in-frame child when it comes to spiders. Anyways, kind of dealt with it. And in Perron, they had some exhibit, some spider exhibit at their local museum. And they had posters for it everywhere. And I think it scarred me a little bit. I also do want to talk about how that spider got into this car, but you know what? We're going to leave that be. Anyways, back to the road trip.
这样大家就能明白了，就好像，是的，说到蜘蛛，我就是一个在画面里显得很小的孩子。总之，这件事算是处理过去了。在皮兰，他们的当地博物馆里有一个展览，某个蜘蛛展览。他们到处都贴着海报。我想这对我造成了一点心理阴影。我还想聊聊那只蜘蛛是怎么进这辆车的，但你知道吗？我们就不管它了。总之，回到公路旅行上来。
Before we move on, though, arachnophobia is the fear of spiders, correct? And then I think acrophobia is the fear of heights. What is agoraphobia? I can never remember that. That's the one where you're afraid of leaving your house. Is it? Yeah. Yeah can never remember that. That's the one where you're afraid of leaving your house. Is it? Yeah. Yeah, I find that fascinating.
不过在我们继续之前，恐蛛症是害怕蜘蛛，对吧？然后我想惧高症是害怕高处。什么是广场恐惧症？我总是记不住。那是那种害怕离开家的情况。是吗？对。对，我总是记不住。那是那种害怕离开家的情况。是吗？对。对，我觉得这挺有意思的。
I love words, love Scrabble, and I always find the fears of topics. I think acrophobia, that's the fear of heights, right? I think so, yeah. Because Acropolis is a building with a tall spire. So I think acro means... Yeah, yeah. And acrobats are jumping through the air. So that makes sense. I did also take two years of Latin in college.
我喜欢文字，喜欢拼词游戏，而且我总是研究各种恐惧症。我想惧高症就是害怕高处，对吧？我想是的，没错。因为卫城（Acropolis）是一座有高尖顶的建筑。所以我觉得 acro 的意思是……对，对。而且杂技演员（acrobat）在空中跳跃。所以这说得通。我在大学里还选修过两年拉丁语。
Not sure that they did anything for me. But that's what I seem to recall. Anyway, so... Yep. 2024. So... What are we going to... Because we called it the Slovenia road trip.
我不确定它们对我有没有什么帮助。但这就是我所能记起来的。总之，所以……没错。2024年。所以……我们要去……因为我们把它叫做斯洛文尼亚公路旅行。
And Slovenia is a country. And so we can't really call it 2023 Africa road trip because Africa is a continent. But we're going to go to multiple countries. So do we call it the Nigeria road trip even though we're going to be in Africa? Well, I think this is the part where we may need to ask for some help from our listeners. First of all, the only place that we know for certain that we want to go on this trip is Nigeria. But we're very open to going to other places. I also know that there's a lot of tech in Kenya.
而斯洛文尼亚是一个国家。所以我们不能真的把它叫作2023年非洲公路旅行，因为非洲是一个大洲。但我们要去多个国家。所以，哪怕我们要去非洲，难道我们要把它叫作尼日利亚公路旅行吗？嗯，我想接下来这一部分，我们可能需要向听众寻求一些帮助。首先，我们这次旅行确定想去的唯一地方是尼日利亚。但我们对去其他地方也非常持开放态度。我也知道肯尼亚有很多科技。
So Kenya is also somewhat on the list. But I would say if you have a recommendation for good countries for us to stop in. Please let us know. Also, if you are in Africa or have ties to Africa and maybe know people who could help us organize some of these meetups, please let us know. We're just starting
所以肯尼亚也在我们的候选名单上。不过我想说，如果你对我们应该在哪些国家停留有好建议，请告诉我们。另外，如果你身在非洲，或者与非洲有联系，或者认识能帮我们组织其中一些粉丝见面会的人，请告诉我们。我们才刚刚开始
to plan this thing. We're looking for ideas, obviously. How many countries in Africa? I have no idea. 54. 54. And we can't go to all of them. Yes. Equatorial Guinea, Chad, Niger.
着手计划这件事。显然我们正在寻找创意。非洲有多少个国家？我完全不知道。54个。54个。我们不可能把它们都去遍。是的。赤道几内亚，乍得，尼日尔。
I used to, I memorized once all 54 African countries. Yes. We should say, you know, we are two privileged white males from Northern America. We know very little about Africa. What? Speak for yourself. Connor, are you not a privileged white male? Oh, no, I am definitely a privileged white male from North America.
我以前，我曾经背过所有54个非洲国家。是的。我们应该说，你知道，我们是两个来自北美的享有特权的白人男性。我们对非洲知之甚少。什么？请代表你自己。康纳，难道你不是一个享有特权的白人男性吗？哦，不，我绝对是一个来自北美的享有特权的白人男性。
It doesn't mean I don't know that much about Africa. I am going to be more humble and say that I don't think that I know that much about Africa and that we definitely are looking for suggestions and recommendations on how to do this. The only thing that I'm fairly certain of is that we will connect through Morocco on our way in, simply because that is the easiest way for me to get us there on airline miles, and that we want to spend some time in Nigeria. And that there will probably not be a driving component of this trip because I do not think that we are qualified to drive through Africa. I think it's going to be easier to fly from country to country than it is going to be to drive from country to country. And, is this correct?
这并不意味着我对非洲一无所知。我会更谦虚一点，说我自认为对非洲了解不多，而且我们确实在寻求关于如何进行这次旅行的建议和推荐。我唯一相当确定的事情是，我们在入境时会在摩洛哥转机，很简单，因为那是让我用航空里程带我们到那里最简单的方式，而且我们想在尼日利亚待上一段时间。并且这次旅行可能不会有开车自驾的部分，因为我认为我们没有资格在非洲开车。我觉得在国家之间坐飞机，会比在国家之间开车要容易得多。而且，对吗？
Yeah, this is correct. I know that most of Africa is completely lovely, but there are definitely certain countries that you want to stay clear of. I'm not going to name any, but you know who you are. Yes. Well, I think we're going to probably, whichever country is going, we're going to probably try to hire a local guide so that we don't get ourselves into trouble. Anyways, we'll figure all this out. We'll figure it all out. All right. So we've got to sign off for now because we're getting pretty close to the scenic viewpoint
对，这话说得没错。我知道非洲大部分地方都完全非常迷人，但也确实有一些你最好远离的特定国家。我不打算点名任何国家，但你们心里有数。是的。嗯，我想我们可能会，无论去哪个国家，我们可能都会试着雇一个当地导游，这样我们就不会惹上麻烦了。总之，我们会把这一切都弄清楚的。我们会搞定这一切的。好了。我们现在得先挂断了，因为我们离风景观景台已经很近了
in Croatia that we came here for. So the plan for today is we're going to go check out one or two things in Croatia, most of which we can say that we've been to Croatia. And then we're going to take a scenic drive to Venice. And this is the last day of the road trip, really. Yeah. Alright. Well, let's sign off.
我们在克罗地亚就是为了这个来的。所以今天的计划是，我们要去克罗地亚看一两个地方，这样大部分情况下我们就可以说我们去过克罗地亚了。然后我们要开车进行一次观光驾驶前往威尼斯。这其实是公路旅行的最后一天了。是的。好吧，那我们挂电话吧。
Peace! Peace? Oh, man. Hello from the wonderful, beautiful country of Italy! Listen, folks, it is, we're back. It's day four, second time recording. We recorded a short episode when we went from Slovenia to Croatia.
拜拜！拜拜？哦，天哪。来自美丽绝伦的意大利的问候！听着，各位，我们回来了。今天是第四天，第二次录制。我们从斯洛文尼亚到克罗地亚时录制了一小集。
It's the Slovenia 2023 road trip. We are on the final leg of our journey en route to Venice. We are in Italy, on the highways of Italy, and we're pretty excited. We've been to three different countries in the last couple hours here, Slovenia, Croatia, and Italy. I won't do my Italian accent that I was doing in the car a while ago, as it is culturally insensitive. And I also, once again, would like to apologize to all of our Italian listeners. I did not know that you were supposed to sip the grappa, and I did start sipping it, because that's what I figured you were supposed to do, but I'll be honest, it was terrible, and I just wanted to get it over with, and I thought that was an alternative method. But we apologize to all of the Italians that live in Italy and outside of Italy and to the country as a whole.
这是2023年斯洛文尼亚公路旅行。我们正处于前往威尼斯之旅的最后一段路程中。我们在意大利，在意大利的高速公路上，我们非常兴奋。在过去的几个小时里，我们已经去过三个不同的国家了：斯洛文尼亚、克罗地亚和意大利。我不会再模仿我刚才在车里用的那种意大利口音了，因为这很不尊重文化。而且我还要再次向我们所有的意大利听众道歉。我不知道原来格拉巴酒（grappa）是应该抿着喝的，而我却开始大口大口地喝了，因为我想象中就应该是那样喝的，但说实话，这酒太糟糕了，我只是想快点把它喝完，我还以为那是另一种喝法。但我们要向所有住在意大利境内外的意大利人以及整个国家致以歉意。
I will not ever shoot a grappa again. Did we talk about the beautiful dinner? We did talk about the beautiful dinner. But I don't think we talked about... No, no, no. We did not? No, no, no. We said we mentioned a bunch of stuff.
我再也不会一口闷格拉巴酒了。我们聊过那顿美妙的晚餐吗？我们确实聊过那顿美妙的晚餐。但我想我们没有聊到……不，不，不。我们没聊吗？不，不，不。我们说我们提到了很多事情。
We mentioned Bryce almost losing his life. We mentioned our truffle dinner. But now, listeners... And Connor nearly dove into a rock today. We're going to cover that too. Oh, no, no, I didn't. No, I didn't. That's not true. So we are going to recap day three. It's day four today. We're going to recap day three, which was eventful. It certainly was eventful. How do we start off day three? We started off day three by gallivanting around the beautiful city of Ljubljana. We went to meet meet. I think we already talked about that. And then we got in the car.
我们提到了布莱斯差点丢了性命。我们提到了我们的松露晚餐。但现在，听众们……还有康纳今天差点一头扎进岩石里。我们也要讲讲这个。哦，不，不，我没有。不，我没有。那不是真的。所以我们要回顾第三天。今天是第四天。我们要回顾一下发生了很多事的第三天。确实发生了很多事。我们第三天是怎么开始的？我们第三天是以在卢布尔雅那这座美丽的城市里闲逛开始的。我们去见了……我想我们已经聊过那个了。然后我们上了车。
I think we recorded an episode yesterday. So we don't need to recap that stuff. So we were en route to Piran on the beautiful coast of Slovenia. It's only a tiny little sliver. Slovenia's only got a little tiny bit, but they still got it. And it's quite a nice bit.
我想我们昨天录过一集了。所以我们不需要回顾那些内容。所以我们在前往斯洛文尼亚美丽海岸线上的皮兰的路上。那只是一小条狭长的海岸。斯洛文尼亚只有那么一小点海岸线，但他们还是拥有了。而且那是一段相当不错的海岸。
It is quite beautiful. I petted a cat this morning. Love it. For about a minute. It was a beautiful kitten. Beautiful kitten. We love the kittens. We love, we love the kittens. We love them. They're very soft and cute and they make us very happy. This
确实相当美丽。我今天早上摸了一只猫。太喜欢了。摸了大约一分钟。那是一只美丽的小猫。美丽的小猫。我们喜欢小猫。我们喜欢，我们喜欢小猫。我们太喜欢它们了。它们非常柔软可爱，让我们感到非常快乐。这
is, this is exactly the content that our listener, our listener is looking for. So, uh, then we went for a little bit of an excursion after we got to Praan, which proved to be unwise. So we were going to walk over to this area, Moon Bay, and we decided we were going to walk instead of driving, which was perhaps our first mistake. So we just looked on Google Maps, and there was a route on Google Maps, and it looked like it was nice, but then there was one part of it where I suggested, well, maybe we can just go by the coast here, even though Google Maps says to not do that. And what happened, Connor? What happened was, you know, it's important.
就是，这正是我们的听众，我们的听众想要的内容。所以，接着我们在到达皮兰后进行了一次短途远足，事实证明这是个不明智的决定。所以我们打算步行去这个地方，月亮湾（Moon Bay），我们决定步行而不是开车，这也许是我们的第一个错误。于是我们查了谷歌地图，上面有一条路线，看起来挺不错的，但后来其中有一段我提议说：“嗯，也许我们可以顺着这边的海岸走，尽管谷歌地图说不要这么走。”然后发生了什么，康纳？发生的事情是，你知道的，这很重要。
We need to really over-index on we had a route. It was a 5.8-kilometer route. And Bryce, for the last kilometer, did not want to take Google's recommendation. And listen, folks, it's been four days of traveling with Bryce. If you want to have a positive traveling experience with Bryce, you have to learn to just, you know, go with the flow. Bryce is a, he's a sensitive soul. You know, the more, the breakfast provided by the hotel this morning was not up to the Royal Highness's standards. So we abandoned the breakfast. And then we couldn't find anything.
我们需要重点强调一下，我们有一条路线。那是一条5.8公里的路线。而布莱斯在最后的一公里里，不想听从谷歌的建议。听着，各位，和布莱斯一起旅行已经四天了。如果你想和布莱斯有一段积极愉快的旅行体验，你必须学会……你知道的，随遇而安。布莱斯是个，他是个敏感的灵魂。你知道，今天早上酒店提供的早餐不符合皇室殿下的标准。所以我们放弃了早餐。然后我们什么也找不到。
And you know what? That's fine. That's fine. But the point is, is Bryce wanted to go along the beach. So we went along the beach first. We encountered many naked people. It was a nudist beach. So we went along the beach. First, we encountered many naked people. It was a nudist beach. There was some speculation by Connor that perhaps it was called Moon Bay because people
你知道吗？没关系。没关系。但重点是，布莱斯想沿着海滩走。所以我们先沿着海滩走了。我们遇到了很多裸体的人。那是一个天体海滩。所以我们沿着海滩走。首先，我们遇到了很多裸体的人。那是一个天体海滩。康纳猜测，这里之所以叫月亮湾，可能是因为
would be mooning there. I think that is probably unlikely. But yes, there was a nudist beach. And we walked by. We were, I think, quite respectful. We were very respectful. We were just trying to get to our destination. Yes. And Bryce was concerned. He did ask me at one point, is it considered disrespectful that we are not nude? Clearly, Bryce, not familiar with how the nude beaches work.
人们会在那里露出屁股（mooning）。我觉得这大概不太可能。不过是的，那确实是一个天体海滩。我们从旁走过。我觉得我们，相当尊重对方。我们非常尊重。我们只是想到达我们的目的地。是的。而布莱斯很担心。他甚至在某个时刻问我：“我们没有赤身裸体，这会被认为是不尊重吗？”显然，布莱斯并不熟悉天体海滩是如何运作的。
Because you obviously have spent a ton of time at nude beaches. I have not, but I did spend, I did spend six years in Vancouver and there's a famous, when I was studying and there's a famous beach called rec beach by UBC that's nude. And we used to go, uh, not frequently, but every once in a while we would go on family walks that happened to go by, but usually it was like early in the morning and there weren't too many people out. So anyways, I ha I just have had experiences. You're allowed to walk through new beaches as long as you're not being, you know So anyways, I just have had experiences. You're allowed to walk through nude beaches as long as you're not being, you know,
因为你显然在天体海滩花过大量的时间。我没有，但我确实在温哥华待过六年，当我还在读书的时候，UBC（不列颠哥伦比亚大学）附近有一个著名的海滩叫雷克海滩（Rec Beach），是个天体海滩。我们过去常去，呃，不是经常，但每隔一段时间我们就会去进行家庭散步，刚好会路过那里，但通常都是一大早，外面没有太多人。所以无论如何，我，我只是有过这种经历。只要你不是在，你知道的，你就可以穿过天体海滩。所以无论如何，我只是有过这种经历。只要你不是在，你知道的，你就可以穿过天体海滩。
impolite or anything. It's totally fine. Anyways, we got past the nude beach, right at the end of the nude beach. The rocky sort of, you know, it was about a five meter, a five meter beach that we were walking along kind of disappeared and we had to go up a hill.
不礼貌或者干别的什么。完全没问题。不管怎样，我们走过了天体海滩，就在天体海滩的尽头。那种岩石质地的，你知道的，我们沿着走了大约五米远的一段海滩突然消失了，我们不得不爬上一座小山。
More of a cliff than a hill. It was halfway between a hill and a cliff. And I will note that there was no discussion about whether we were going to go up it. Connor just raced up the hill. And I expressed my concerns that this was an unwise path for us to take. And that we should maybe reconsider our plans. First of all, first of all, folks, I didn't race up the hill. If you, if I was racing, you'd know, you'd know. Okay. I'm real fast when I race and I wasn't racing up no hill. In fact, if anything, I was
与其说是小山，不如说是悬崖。它处于小山和悬崖之间的一半。我要指出的是，当时我们并没有讨论究竟要不要爬上去。康纳直接就冲上了山。而我则表达了我的担忧，认为这不是一条明智的路线，我们也许应该重新考虑我们的计划。首先，首先，各位，我并没有冲上山。如果，如果我是飞奔的话，你们会知道的，你们会知道的。好吧。我跑起来可快了，我才没有往任何山上飞奔呢。事实上，如果说有什么的话，那就是我当时
quite cautious because I do agree. It was quite, uh, quite steep and, uh, I saw no such caution. Okay, well, I was being cautious. But, you know, I'm at one in the wilderness and I was not intimidated and I wanted to get to this Moon Bay and it looked beautiful in the photos. We actually did see it today. We drove up and then forced a lady to drive backwards
相当谨慎，因为我确实同意，那条路，相当陡峭，而且我没看到什么谨慎可言。好吧，我当时挺谨慎的。但是，你知道的，我融入了大自然，我没有被吓退，而且我想去这个月亮湾，它在照片里看起来美极了。我们今天其实去过了。我们开车上去，然后强迫一位女士倒车
for a while. Very unclear where one parks at this Moon Bay and we went on a very rural one-way road and did some very intense maneuvering to get up and then back down and were unable to find a place to park and then to go hike down to it but we decided that Moon Bay had defeated us twice and we would just have to come back some other time. Yep. So we did see it from afar. And spoiler, kind of, that we did not end up making it to Moon Bay yesterday. And so at a certain point, we realized that there's no path at the edge of this cliff.
倒了一会儿。在月亮湾这里到底把车停在哪非常不明确，我们走了一条非常偏僻的单行道，做了一些非常激烈的驾驶操作才上去，然后又退下来，结果找不到停车的地方，也就没法徒步走下去，但我们觉得月亮湾已经把我们打败两次了，我们只能改天再来。是的。所以我们确实从远处看到了它。剧透一下，就是我们昨天最后没能去成月亮湾。所以到了一定的时候，我们意识到这个悬崖边上根本没有路。
It's got a pretty steep drop-off on the left. And so we sort of cut in, but then it didn't look too, it wasn't too clear if there was a path, because Google said that there was an alternative path, but it clearly wasn't where we were. And then at some point we said, okay, we've got to go back down, or Bryce, you know, starts to go back down. And then? Then I slipped and fell maybe, I don't know, 10, 15 feet. And I hurt myself a little bit, got a couple scratches on my arm, didn't get my finger. But in my defense, in my defense, one, I said this is a bad idea to go up there.
左边是一个相当陡峭的下坡。所以我们稍微往内侧切过去，但接着又显得不太对劲，是不是有路也不太清楚，因为谷歌说有条替代路线，但显然不在我们所在的地方。然后到了某个时刻，我们说，好了，我们得往下走，或者说布莱斯，你知道的，开始往下走。然后呢？然后我滑倒并摔了下去，大概有，我不知道，10、15英尺深。我受了一点小伤，胳膊上擦伤了几处，手指倒没伤到。但为我自己辩护一下，为我自己辩护一下，第一，我说过往那里走是个坏主意。
Two, I was the one carrying the bag, and it was not a proper hiking bag. It was just a bag over my shoulder. And the weight of that, I think, made it a little bit tricky to essentially climb up this cliff, which we were attempting to do. And three, the trail shoes that I had with me are on their last limb. They've got a pretty substantial hole in the sole, and the treads are worn down and this is going to be their last trip and i was not anticipating the need to uh climb up a cliff uh although connor connor seemed uh connor seemed to be very interested in doing that listen folks we got a couple things to clear up here one is that when bryce says the bag which makes it sound like it's a it's a shared common bag. It's his bag, okay?
第二，我是那个背着包的人，而且那不是一个合适的徒步背包。它只是一个挂在我肩膀上的包。我认为那个重量，使得我们实际上试图爬上这个悬崖变得有点棘手，而我们当时正试图这么做。第三，我随身带的徒步鞋已经快寿终正寝了。鞋底有一个相当大的洞，鞋底花纹都磨损了，这本来将是它们的最后一次旅行，而我并没有预料到需要去爬一段悬崖——尽管康纳，康纳看起来，康纳似乎对做这件事非常感兴趣。听着，各位，我们有几件事要澄清一下，其中一点是，当布莱斯说“这个包”时，听起来好像这是一个共享的公共背包。这明明是他的包，好吗？
I did not have a bag because I didn't need a bag. All I brought was a towel. It had all of the things that you might need as well, like a phone charger and, you know, a phone and wallet in case we needed to pay for things. Those are not all your things. No, no, the other things. Those are not all your things.
我没有背包，因为我不需要背包。我只带了一条毛巾。里面装着你可能需要的所有东西，比如手机充电器，还有，你知道的，以防我们需要付钱时的手机和钱包。这些可不全是你需要的东。不，不，另外的东西。那可不全是你需要的东。
Yes, but look, it's always good to come prepared. If I needed something, I'd run back. No big deal. Okay your things. Yes. But look, it's always good to come prepared. If I needed something, I'd run back. No big deal. Okay, okay. Anyways, long story short, we eventually got down. Whoa, whoa, whoa. We're not done. We're not done with this. From my point of view, folks, you've got to understand.
是的，但听着，有备无患总归是好的。如果我需要什么，我可以跑回去拿。这没什么大不了的。好吧，你的东西。是的。但听着，有备无患总归是好的。如果我需要什么，我可以跑回去拿。这没什么大不了的。好吧，好吧。不管怎样，长话短说，我们最后总算下去了。等等，等等，等等。我们还没完呢。关于这个，我们还没完呢。从我的角度来看，各位，你们必须明白。
I did think that momentarily we lost Bryce because when he slipped and fell, it's a very steep hill. And below us were just a bunch of trees and, like, sort of bushes. So you got to understand, within a second, he slipped, fell down the mountain, and started sliding away. And there was a lot more to go. He could have gone, instead of just 10 or 15 feet, he could have gone, like, a full 30 or 40. I caught a hold of him. And he caught a hold of something. But I'm just watching Bryce disappear.
我确实以为有那么一会儿我们把布莱斯弄丢了，因为当他滑倒摔下去时，那是一座非常陡峭的山。而我们下方只是一堆树木和，呃，类似灌木丛的东西。所以你们得明白，在一秒钟之内，他滑倒了，从山上摔了下来，然后开始往下滑。而且下面还有很长一段路。他本可能不仅滑下10或15英尺，他本可能会滑下，比如说，整整30或40英尺。我抓住了他。而他抓住了一些东西。但我当时眼睁睁看着布莱斯消失。
And I'm thinking, oh, shit, like, I killed Bryce. Technically, it would have been his own fault. Nope, it was definitely Connor's fault. Connor went up there. I felt obligated to fall. You were the one that did not fall attention. Right, right. That was correct, but I did not make the decision to go up the cliff.
我心想，哦，操，我把布莱斯给害死了。严格来说，这得怪他自己。不，绝对得怪康纳。是康纳往上走的。我觉得自己有义务摔下去。你才是那个没有引起注意的人。对，对。这话说得没错，但我并没有做出往悬崖上爬的决定。
You made that decision. I'm just saying. We wouldn't have been in that situation in the first place if we just listened to google that is true i will admit that anyways it was all good at the end of the day i did i did ask bryce if he needed to go to the hospital which uh it was definitely not that level of uh of injury however i uh i did in the moment you were uh i was concerned yes yeah um yeah it was uh Yeah, it was not great. But then this morning, when we were in Croatia, we went and swam off of the Istrian Peninsula, the Croatian part,
那个决定是你做的。我只是这么说。如果我们一开始听谷歌的话，我们就不会陷入那种境地了，这倒是真的，我承认。不管怎样，到头来一切都好，我确实，我确实问过布莱斯他需不需要去医院，呃，那绝对没有达到那种受伤程度，不过，我，我当时确实，你，我当时很担心，对，是的，呃，是的，呃，是的，感觉不太妙。但今天早上，当我们在克罗地亚时，我们去了伊斯特拉半岛的海里游泳，那是克罗地亚的一部分，
and it was beautiful. The water was gorgeous, perfect temperature. But everywhere that we've gone that's had water, Connor has just decided to just dive right in without, I think, really giving any appropriate consideration to whether or not it is a safe spot to dive. No. And this day, he did two dives, and on the second dive, there was some slipping of the
风景优美极了。水清澈见底，温度刚刚好。但我们去过的所有有水的地方，康纳都直接决定一跃而下，我觉得他根本没有好好考虑过这到底是不是一个适合跳水安全的地方。没有。而在这一天，他跳了两次水，在第二次跳水时，他的双脚
feet, and there was maybe some concern that you were going to crack your skull in the water, which I've been worried about all week. First of all, first of all, to say that I took no consideration is absolutely false. I got in the water before I dived to check how deep it was because— You did not do that at Blood Lake. I didn't at Blood Lake, but that's because I could visually tell. I could visually tell. That water was so clear, and, yeah, so I didn't at Blood Lake, but that's because I could visually tell. I could visually tell. That water was so clear. And, yes, I didn't at Blood Lake.
似乎有些打滑，而且可能让人有点担心你会不会在水里把头骨撞裂，这可是我一星期以来一直在担心的事情。首先，首先，说我完全没有考虑，这绝对是无稽之谈。我在跳水之前就下水去检查过水有多深了，因为——你在血湖（Blood Lake）时可没这么做。我在血湖没这么做，那是因为我肉眼就能看出来。我肉眼就能看出来。那里的水太清澈了，而且，是的，我在血湖没这么做，那是因为我肉眼就能看出来。我肉眼就能看出来。那里的水太清澈了。而且，是的，我在血湖没这么做。
This one, it was, you've got to understand, is that the coast of Croatia and Slovenia where we have been has been completely rocks and rocky. And where we were in Croatia, it's definitely, it was definitely pretty, like, you know, rocky. Anyways, there was this, like, little boat launch where on the edges you could walk out. But I hopped in the water, checked how deep it was. It was about, you know, 1.5 meters, I'd say.
这个嘛，你得明白，我们去过的克罗地亚和斯洛文尼亚海岸全都是岩石。我们在克罗地亚呆的地方，绝对可以说是相当多岩石的。不管怎样，那里有一个小船坞，边缘可以走人。但我跳进水里试了一下深度，大概有1.5米深吧。
Which is definitely not great. Not great. But as long as you're doing a shallow dive, which I, of course, know how to do. You're all good. First dive was fantastic, wonderful. And the second dive, my feet slipped a little bit. So it wasn't, I didn't execute well. And it could have been bad.
这绝对算不上太好。真的不算好。不过只要你做浅水跳水，我当然是会这招的，那就没问题。第一次跳水棒极了，非常美妙。第二次跳水时，我的脚稍微滑了一下。所以动作没做好，其实本来可能会出事的。
It wasn't. I just thought to myself, you know what? Even though we got 1.5 meters here, the rock is a little bit too wet. So no more dives. And for you to put that in the same category, I'm completely unscathed. No injuries, no blood. I wouldn't even call it a near miss. I have been pretty concerned every time you have boldly dove into the water.
但并没有出事。我当时就想，你知道吗？虽然这里有1.5米深，但岩石有点太滑了。所以不能再跳了。如果你把这归为同一类的话，我完全毫发无伤。没有受伤，没有流血。我甚至都不会称之为险情。每次你大胆地跳进水里时，我都相当担心。
But then what else did we do we we drove we drove from croatia back into slovenia and then uh we drove through the city of truste and then we stopped briefly at a castle um miramar castle i think all right along the coast it was beautiful and lovely. And now we are about an hour out from Venice. And we're going to go to Venice. We're going to meet up with one of my friends and get some dinner.
但后来我们还做了什么呢？我们从克罗地亚开车返回斯洛文尼亚，然后我们驱车穿过里雅斯特市，接着我们在一个城堡短暂停留，嗯，好像是米拉马雷城堡，就在海岸边，非常美丽可爱。现在我们距离威尼斯大约只有一个小时的车程了。我们要去威尼斯，去和我的一个朋友碰面吃晚饭。
Check out Venice. Maybe try to find one of those little boats with the men who serenade you as they butcher around the city. What do we think about that? That sounds fantastic. Never been to Venice. I'm also, I have to say,
去看看威尼斯。也许想找那种小船，船夫会一边在城里摇船一边对你唱小夜曲。大家觉得怎么样？听起来太棒了。我从没去过威尼斯。而且我必须得说，
I mean, this is not my running podcast. I have a running podcast for those that care. Run for the fun of it. But this morning I also did go for a very short 7K run because I wanted to wake up at 6, but thanks to the grappa, I forgot to set my alarm and only woke up at 7.30, and we didn't have that much time
我的意思是，这不是我的跑步播客。关心的人可以去听我的跑步播客《Run for the fun of it》。但今天早上我也去跑了一个非常短的7公里，因为我想6点醒来，但多亏了格拉帕酒，我忘定闹钟了，直到7点半才醒，而且我们没有那么多时间
because we needed to get on the road. But I ended up running 84 streets this morning which is for seven kilometers absolutely ridiculous. We love we love these little Roman-esque cities with small back alleyways because they're so road and street dense and so looking forward to venice we're going to be going on a couple big runs as soon as bryce leaves we can get back to running uh our our full distances 15k 20k very excited for venice and uh yeah now we can switch to because we didn't talk about this on the pod what was it a couple days ago when we were chatting in the car and we were talking about some algorithm stuff and I asked Bryce. And so now I'll put it to the listener.
因为我们需要上路了。但我今天早上居然跑了84条街道，对于7公里来说简直太荒谬了。我们太喜欢这种带有狭窄小巷的古罗马风格城市了，因为它们的道路和街道密度太高了。非常期待威尼斯，布莱斯一走我们就去进行几次长跑，这样我们就能恢复跑步了，我们的全距离15公里、20公里。非常兴奋能去威尼斯，嗯，现在我们可以转换话题了，因为几天前我们在车里聊天时没有在播客里谈到这个，当时我们在讨论一些算法方面的东西，我问了布莱斯。现在我把它抛给听众。
If you're washing dishes, if you're on a run, if you're on a walk, or if you're just sitting on the couch or sitting in a chair in the backyard enjoying the sunshine, think about this. So we've got... Tune in next week to hear our discussion of this algorithm problem. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the things we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a GitHub discussion where you can leave questions, comments, or thoughts. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline.
如果你在洗碗，如果在跑步，如果在散步，或者如果你正坐在沙发上或后院的椅子上享受阳光，好好想想这个。所以我们有……请收听下周的节目，听听我们对这个算法问题的讨论。请务必查看你的播客应用中的节目shownotes，或者访问ADSPthepodcast.com获取今天节目中提到任何事物的链接，以及一个可以留下问题、评论或想法的GitHub讨论区。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有个美好的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的标语。其实不是这个标语。
Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的标语是“点缀着知识碎屑的混乱”。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。